hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
this viral math meme is breaking the
internet and getting a lot of media
coverage
230 minus 220 divided by two
it appears the math phd is saying a
different answer than 120
so who is right
we can evaluate this expression using
the order of operations this is commonly
referred to as pemdas or bodmus
so first we're going to evaluate the
division
we take 220 divided by 2 and we get the
result of 110
we then evaluate the subtraction of 230
minus 110 and we get the answer of 120
and this is without a doubt the correct
answer to this expression
now you could evaluate it from left to
right but that would be the wrong way
some people might do 230 minus 220
this would simplify to be 10 and then 10
divided by 2 is equal to 5.
but this is definitely the wrong answer
so the confusion is why is the math phd
saying the answer is 5
well if you look closely the math phd is
not saying the answer is 5 the math phd
is actually saying 5 exclamation point
this is a mathematical notation for
factorial
five factorial is equal to five times
four times three times two times one and
that evaluates to be a hundred and
twenty
so if you go back to the original mean
both of them are saying the answer is a
hundred and twenty
so both answers are correct and it's a
little bit of a math joke
it's a fun one that you can share and
you can actually cause a lot of
accidental arguments
but you'll know the correct answer
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you